Without acknowledging failure.
Russia's top
general in Ukraine
announced an apparent retreat
from her son.
When you might have to watch a approach
to address any of those over I.
This is a very difficult decision.
At the same time, we will save,
most importantly,
the lives of our troops.
And the overall combat
effectiveness of the troops.
An admission of defeat
that has been foreshadowed
for several weeks
Civilians forced to evacuate
east across the strategic
to Dnipro River.
The Russian flag gone from her son's
main administrative building
Fewer troops on city streets.
Russian checkpoints in the city go on
and significantly Tuesday night,
blowing several key
bridges on front lines
to slow Ukraine's advance.
All indicative,
they're readying for retreat.
Ukrainian officials remain cautious
Presidential adviser
Michela Poggioli tweeting.
Actions speak louder than words.
We see no signs
Russia is leaving her son
without a fight.
Ukraine is liberating territories
based on intelligence data, not stage
two statements.
Complicating their assessment,
the sudden death Wednesday of a senior
Russian installed
official, Kirill Strome moves off
in a road traffic accident.
According to Russian state media.
Precise details or the implication
still unclear.
Regardless, the retreat immediate
some troops to stay close
fight from the East
Bank of the Deni Pro River.
Others to bolster other fronts
were part of the forces
and means will be released,
which will be used for active operations,
including offensive ones
in other directions
in the operation zone.
Losing her son is a huge blow
to Putin, captured
in the opening days of the war.
It will be the first regional capital
to be retaken by Ukraine.
Less than six weeks since Putin
illegally annexed it
and declared it part of Russia.
Ukrainian forces
have been readying
to retake her song for months
and finally appear poised to do so.
If it's not a trap.
Nic Robertson, CNN, Kramatorsk, Ukraine.
Vladimir Solecki is among those who doubt
that Russian forces
plan to retreat from us on anytime soon.
Ukraine's president and first lady Scott
sat down for an exclusive interview
with CNN's Christiane Amanpour.
Zelenskiy said his troops will proceed
with caution, take no unnecessary risks
when it comes to fashion.
He also told Christiane
Russia has been sending mixed messages
about its real intentions.
Positive tone.
They hope to win.
So they are ready to defend this region
and they are not ready to leave the city.
And the fact that they are in these homes
means that they are seriously preparing.
But we are also seriously prepared
for these developments.
But we are not considering this as just
one single operation.
We have a strategy
and different directions.
He did not give them
the full interview
with Zelinsky on Amanpour.
That's 6:00
in the evening in London, AP in Kiev
right here
with Christiane Amanpour on CNN.
Let's go live now to Key Football
that Salma Abdulazeez is joining us
with the very latest.
So we're expecting this sort of battle
focus on any time soon, any moment.
It does appear that the Russians
are sending in their elite forces,
if any, if if anything, and the officials
have been withdrawing
It's really a startling
admission of defeat that we're seeing.
John announced yesterday
in this press conference
with Russia's defense minister
standing alongside
Sergei
Sorokin, the top general in charge
of Russia's military operation here.
And they made the argument
in this press conference
that they could no longer
supply Russian troops and course on that
they needed to pull back
to the east side of the deeper river
to fortify their positions,
their presence.
Lynskey
commented on this in his nightly address,
saying The enemy does not give us gifts,
essentially saying
he will proceed with caution
that there might be a trap,
an attempt to lure Ukrainian forces.
But already
Ukrainian officials say
they're seeing Russian troops withdraw
from these frontline
villages,
that they're blowing up bridges
all along the deeper river.
You would assume, of course,
in anticipation of a Ukrainian advance.
And, yes,
a huge blow to President Putin,
but in some ways not surprising, John.
We have for days now
heard these reports
that there is
a lessened
Russian presence
in force on less checkpoints.
Also,
civilians, families have been evacuated,
forced out of their homes
essentially over
the last few weeks, forced
to the east side of the river as well.
So, yes,
Ukrainian forces
proceeding with caution
here, asking the question,
what state will they leave
Krystle and city in?
Will it be booby trapped?
Will there be mind set?
How realistic is this announcement?
But again, just a startling blow back.
I mean, John,
just six weeks ago,
President Putin was illegally annexing
this territory
in a very glitzy ceremony to now
admit defeat, pull back.
It's massive.
John,
you know,
it makes you wonder
what's going on, doesn't it?
Selma, thank you so much.
Felicity's and Keith.